es zeigt auch mal wieder wie
heuchlerisch eigentlich die EU ist und
es wird eine bargeldobergrenze von 10
000 € klar gemacht und selber haben die
600.000 € zu Hause in Plastiksäcken
rumlegen aber erste Frage natürlich
erste Punkt was hat denn die FIFA mit
der EU gemeinsam erstens sie sind
korrupt und zweitens haben sich von
Katar schmieren lassen ja Eva kaeli
vizekommissionspräsidentin der EU hat
Geld angenommen von Katar um Werbung für
den Wüsten statt zu machen und hat damit
den größten korruptionskandal in der
Geschichte der EU ausgelöst nur einer
von vielen die EU seit jeher eigentlich
immer wieder bekannt durch Skandale
durch Korruption und wir wissen ja der
Fisch stinkt immer vom Kopf meine
einzige nach ist die EU moralisch
ethisch geschaltet wenn Sie sich jetzt
nicht reformiert dann wird sie auch noch
implodieren weil die Menschen verlieren
immer mehr das Vertrauen in die
Institution EU und vor allem auch in die
nicht teilweise demokratisch
legitimierten Führer der Institution der
Europäischen Union